ch
ou celui qui a fait ça vous aimez pas
beaucoup d'ordre juste là y'a un truc il
ya un truc pareil
franchement c'est super je pense du coup
c'est bien faire on va la faire aller sa
moto ou d'ordre balawi chiffonné dans
les pmu avec mes potes et les blousons
noirs
alors en ce moment on commence avec
quatuor alors comme vous le savez enfin
en télé il ya deux types de chroniqueurs
il ya ceux qui sont en plateau et il ya
ceux qui sont à l'extérieur les envoyés
spéciaux à genoux en plateau on a de la
chance on a les maquilleurs et les
coiffeuses l'extérieur ils ont pas la
même chose que ceux qui présentent il
est bombardé avec là c'est sûr qu'ils
assurent qu'il a moins de problèmes
bon on fait tout ça je ne crache pas sur
mes cheveux non moi non plus jamais
c'est pour maintenant ah non non non
c'est dégueulasse mes cheveux d'ailleurs
sur personne d'ailleurs
ça c'est votre délire regarde pas après
ça j'ai regardé aussi le sport que
personne ne regarde son équipe 21 à
domicile presque la mailing alors je
suis désolé de vous décevoir c'est le
mode des femmes marchent très bien alors
on aurait pas de vrai bayador trop bien
fonctionné parce que c'est le soir de la
catastrophe notre la marche très bien on
te dis mais y aura donc le dis que ça
marche très bien alors ce serait bien
bon bah du coup c'est une émission sur
lesquels ils ont d'énormes moyens y
compris quand il s'agit de départager
deux équipes ils ont mis au point un
moyen technologique que tous les jeux
télé leurs envies prends-ça fort boyard
une première équipe démarre et une
deuxième équipe ensuite prend le relais
qui va démarrer dès ou mode qu'est ce
que tu choisis mais d'accord
mais voilà alors ça cartonne pas
vraiment non
mais l'enseigné pour 8000 numéro après
numéro
[Rires]
l'espace alors ce qui est sympa aussi
avec eux avec le mode dette c'est que
bas le concept est simple c'est des gens
qui rentrent dans la bombe au cou ou du
coup les règles on les rase et
accessible quoique quand on regarde
l'émission on a l'impression que c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de ramper dans
la boue que de lancer une fusée
l'aller simple pour être première
épreuve vous devez passer ses couloirs
de boue un par un le premier passe il
revient il a chargé le deuxième puis ils
partent à 2 puis à 3 puis à 4 et vous
fait l'épreuve deux fois franchie à 4,2
fois les couloirs de boue je vous
attends au quiz
je me déçoit c'est une émission
dangereuse dans laquelle on peut se
faire de ces verbes et sur vraiment
sévère voilà léa est blessé léa qu'est
ce qui s'est passé et qu'est ce que tu
ressens
enfin beaucoup de déception ah oui je
comprends qu est ce que tu as exactement
déjà je me suis bien n'est as mis le
genou sur un caillou il faut que tu
abandonnes jeudi
on connaît maintenant les héros ou le
bon bout et dans cette émission ils n'en
font pas trop hein quand il parle de
l'état on n'a pas du tout l'impression
qu'elle vient de périr dans un terrible
accident aux dates de malédiction au tas
de la malchance au delà d'accidents et
par amour évidemment pour lire vous
allez faire un truc extraordinaire tous
les trois arbitres l'habite willin pas
marché mais c'était lundi le jour de
l'incendié il faut laisser deuxième chef
nama marché et c'est normal non et bien
si c'est quand même vos infos 02 tout ce
qu'on a déjà vu en type tue plus de son
avis merci on n'a pas le droit de dire
du mal ces savants alors je ne produis
absolument pas reprend la biennale amis
pour prendre la défense du bien et lyon
2-2 d'aventuré on a des fiches et je
bouge les faits dans cette excellente
émission k challenge qui n'a pas échappé
à gilbert meyer et c'est vrai que la
fiche
honnêtement quand même quand on la lit
on comprend pas surtout quand c'est vous
qui lisez
[Rires]
voilà on va enchaîner
merci je suis passé sur les télés
locales c'est mon nouveau dada du coup
je suis passé sur 1 2 3 musette pour
ceux qui connaissent pas c'est
l'équivalent des nrj music awards mais
pour les fans de bal musette du coup
c'est pas tout à fait dans la norme
alors j'essaie d'écouter cela alors
c'est diffusé sur plein de chaînes y
compris d'iptv alors c'est aussi la
question je me poserai voulait avancer
justement alors c'est bien sûr ce type
d'émission c'est que tous les artistes
et bien pour faire leur promo tous sauf
un quentin qui lui a pas vraiment bossé
sa promo ercis venu avec votre trompes
de chasse au cerf alors un mot sur cet
instrument de
heureusement il est un peu plus à l'aise
pour parler tout l'album non je déconne
et aujourd'hui vous êtes venu nous
présenter cet album en pis
un petit mot sur votre actualité merci
beaucoup
quentin vous restez avec nous j'ai aussi
remarqué qu'un accordéoniste pouvait pas
faire de chorégraphies excellent du coup
il en fait avec son visage
ça fait super flipper
[Musique]
oh
cecileb je sais pas combien d'années ça
cartonnait sur france 3 régional en
lorraine y avait tous les abonnés samedi
après-midi gamme et du bal musette etc
etc c'est exactement ma balle mais c'est
drôle
elles vont dire leurs aînés balue et lui
ils dorment les cendres étaient
impropres l'accordéon obélix eu la
chance aux chansons la chance aux gens
sont allés alors on enchaîne suis passé
sur par pending c'est la chaîne locale
marseillaise les diabètes accents tarpin
bien voilà alors à tarte un bien est à
repenser une expression mart exactement
c'est génial quoi ces tarpans bien alors
pour prouve à bien son pouvoir leur
émission ils ont décidé d'organiser une
petite soirée du coup ils sont allés
faire un micro trottoir sans de la
soirée et c'est là que j'ai compris qu'à
marseille on dit tout ce qu'on pense
peut-être un peu trop parfois
anaïs bonsoir comment ça va mais écoutez
ça va très bien qu'est-ce que tu es venu
faire ici ce soir mais je suis venu me
bourrer la gueule et rentrait pas tout
seul
voilà heureusement nice a désamorcé
juste après expliquant qu'elle était
très sélective en presque moi j'aime
tout temps qu'ils sont gentils et qui me
paye des coûts j'ai remarqué que cette
soirée les gens interrogés oublie
facilement qu'ils sont filmés dernier
comme un ça va
c'est très envie de pisser cellule en or
et urcar paniqué on sait recevoir ses
invités comme il se doit ça fait plaisir
pour preuve est avec nous comment savoir
oui ben je suis très ému d'être parmi
vous ouais c'est qu'on avait besoin
d'une gonzesse pour parler de ce film on
n'a pas le choix
je rappelle que je rappelle bien sûr que
l'abus d'alcool est dangereux pour la
monarchie était exactement qu'il faut le
consommer avec merci beaucoup